bonjour monsieur le maire de
sainte-marie qui comme à bien d'autres
comme bien des français comme bien des
martiniquais à attendre à la déclaration
du président la république à suivre sur
toutes les antennes de la première il
s'exprimera le président la république à
l'issue de l'exercice du grand débat
national en tant que maire en tant qu
ancien député en tant que citoyen vous
espérez quoi d'abord je crois avoir
entendu le président dire hier soir
qu'il l'a entendu il a entendu donc
qu'elle répondra donc je ne veux pas
être peu plus impatients que cela donc
j'attends et à partir de cela je vais
peut-être des réactions sûrement mais
savait que l'exercice sera périlleux
pour lui devant la raréfaction des
ressources surtout financière en tout
cas c'est dans ce contexte national qui
arrivera là car ils vont très vite les
élections européennes boulonnais soit à
zéro il ya quelques jours
manuela qui clarmont désir votre
suppléant à l'assemblée nationale qui
vous a remplacé à la chambre basse a
affirmé qu'elle soutiendra max orville
et la liste renaissance de la majorité
présidentielle pour le scrutin du 25 mai
dit tout tout ce matin est ce qu'il ya
eu concertation avant ce soutien
annoncées à max orville à la liste
renaissance entre vous et elle rappelé
tout simplement que manuela réclame au
désir à l'époque avant d'être député a
été ma remplaçante ma suppléante est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une parlementaire
député de la république française député
de la martinique et que c'est une femme
libre qui a fait un choix libre donc
j'ai pris acte tout simplement rappeler
on sait qu'à une année sera zéro dit
qu'il prend acte ça veut dire qu'il
n'est pas forcément d'accord je rappelle
que manuel avec l'harmonie c'est une
députée libre qui a fait un show that
moment donné gauche démocrate et
républicaine dans l'opposition au
président marc roy la soirée sera elle
de s'expliquer au sein de son groupe
je ne suis plus parlementaire je suis
maire de sète marie tu plus député c'est
manu la negra modelo qui affiche quoi
vous avez géré par cette déclaration
parce que je crois que max aux villes et
aux martiniquais que parmi tant d'autres
comme tant d'autres qu'il soit intéressé
pour vous inscrire ou est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous parleriez de
déception nous sommes bien à froid ça
fait quelques jours que cette
déclaration était faible
parleriez doit froid 2
déception de trahison mais pas du tout
je ne veux pas non pas ce ne sont pas
mes mots
manuela l'écran maurizio c'est une
députée c'est une femme libre qui a fait
un choix legs en il choisit un candidat
pour les européennes au sein de votre
formation politique à cette marie lemay
le mouvement d'initiative populaire
je me suis laissé dire que youn de a day
o pas content for pas les dix ans
notamment le 5 mai ce sera la date de
votre assemblée générale c'est quand un
grand moment sept maris effectivement à
la maison du bèlè et d'ailleurs j'espère
que les médias seront là pour vous allez
parler de sa nouvelle palais du tout
bail puisque m'a jamais fait quelque
chose qu'elle ait quoi que ce soit
vraiment ce n'est pas un sujet social le
sujet ce sujet mineur d'accord l'argent
c'est le nerf de la guerre se pose la
question du financement des partis
madame la députée verte serait-elle
encore d'une somme liée à son activité
de parlementaires au mip
mais bien sûr dès le départ c'est à nous
dire il toujours tienne parole du mal à
passer kitchen est toujours bon ces
élections européennes puisque vous ne
voulez pas nous dire si vous êtes
franchement déçu ou ont senti trahi
ces élections européennes que dites-vous
aux martiniquais boon les sauts à 0 ce
sera dans quelques jours dans quelques
semaines intéressez-vous à l'union
européenne c'est ce que vous direz en
martinique m intéressez-vous à ces
élections
tellement l'europe est avec nous dans
notre quotidien c'est vrai que en tant
que maire de sète barry j'ai eu à
mobiliser des fonds européens pour faire
avancer mon territoire pour le
développer donc je ne peux pas dire que
je ne suis pas intéressé par les
élections européennes soient vous
soutiendrez qui pour le moment il me
semble que nos pratiques pour vous même
sarko mesurer vos et est-ce que ça a été
le sujet du journal justement ya pas eu
de positionnement n'y a pas eu de choix
définis d'objat ans justement que ces
choix-là s'opère et à partir de ça ça je
vais choisir pour se neutraliser savais
pas pour qui vous ne m'en sers beaucoup
plutôt tendance de gauche
regardons tous candidats éventuellement
vous car il répond que tout a adopté la
whey l'europe en tout cas qui auraient
pu être votre partenaire pour mettre sur
pied un véritable réseau de transport
communal peu comme le lorrain un peu
comme le monde pourquoi ça n'a pas été
le cas cette marie et bien tout
simplement parce que mozilla le temps
vous savez très bien que aujourd'hui la
compétence transport et est dévolu à la
martinique traoré pulmo leur siège en
avant
bien sûr qu on aurait pu faire beaucoup
de choses bien avant mais
malheureusement quand vous regardez bien
le transport organisé sur la ville du
gaumont ou helmut peut-être une
vingtaine d'années sur la ville du lot
mais à peu près une quinzaine d'années
mais bien ça allait à peu près veto donc
moi aussi maire de cette marque depuis
dix seulement vous attendez que ce soit
martigues sport qui prévue sur les gains
en capital s'améliore pas les problèmes
naissants zéro de la politique
martiniquaise c'était la création de
payer à nouveau venu sur la scène
politique avec un co présidence
marcellin nadeau maire du prêcheur et
votre ami votre frère jean-philippe ni
lors vous avez été bien silencieux
depuis le 3 février date de création de
cette nouvelle formation robert ce matin
dites nous ce que vous pensez de
l'arrivée de ce nouveau parti politique
je te parle politique c'est un nouveau
parti politique qui arrive de qu'il faut
saluer celles et ceux qui l'ont crié
cependant jacques nolot demeure et
restera toujours un ami mais pas un ami
politique je l'aï toujours dit je suis
très à l'aise pour le réaffirmer ici ce
matin
cependant je n'ai pas été jugé tort si
je le dis que je simple de distanciation
dans vos propos là ce matin mais l'ami
le frère mais j'ai toujours dit que je
n'étais pas un ami ouais tout court un
ami politique on pas jamais du mime
mais moi ce que lui-même nous sommes
laquelle avril est-ce que depuis le 3
février vous avez parlé avec lui
directement à l'occasion de pau quelques
pensées en ce sens et on sait qu une
fois oui une fois nous avons eu à
discuter une fois ou des amis des frères
ça mais au moins du monde y est là d'un
moment de vérité ou pas mme wade quand
même cas modibo n'ont donc nous une fois
nous raconter qu une fois vous vous êtes
dit quoi concernant pays à pays à qui
laisse pays mouvement politique
l'accueil mettait sur pied - bientôt
vous savez lorsque vous évite quelque
part quand vous invite à déjeuner ou à
dîner
oui avant de vous recevoir et vous
demander ce que vous faites des
allergies à tel ou tel aliment les jov
l'ethnie low cost cuit pays acp et puis
mon seul et nadau c'est son choix je
n'ai jamais
étaient invités je n'ai jamais été
consulté et on nous demande d'être à la
table
cela n'est pas possible comme on peut
toujours avoir des délégués quasi
l'exactitude concernant la perception
des choses
je vous pose la question il ya de
l'amertume dans vos propos et un peu de
déception parce que tout le monde le
pensait et tout le monde imaginait qui
voyait un partenariat entre gênes et
livourne et les studios combien coup mon
profil est né le concept ça non je ne
règle pas je suis dans un moment de
vérité
vous m'avez invité sur le plateau pour
dire ce qui s'est passé donc s'ils n'ont
pas envie de ça ou qu'on est même en ce
moment à désamorcer municipaux matière
donc je retrace jeudi exactement l'état
d'esprit dans lequel je me trouve
aujourd'hui vous êtes déçu mais entre
amis on peut avoir des hausses de forme
des pics de forme des baisses de forme
depuis le temps ça fait quand même un
mois et demi vous avez pu vous dire bon
jean philippe marcellin bon que
pouvons-nous faire ensemble pour se
payer mais je n'ai jamais dit gg nous
n'avons ressenti de ce qui s'est passé
mais cependant de mener paris fait
passer donc on peut aussi rimer
deviendrait de même à trouver toutes les
manières mot viol tôt vous le savez
cette marie pèsera dans ces élections de
la 7e à la menace est maintenant je n'ai
menacé personne mais tout comme ça
maintenant la question que vous auriez
dû me poser c'est avec qui oui avec qui
mais ce n'est là mon programme mais il
est évident que cette marie joua un rôle
majeur de ces élections là et tous les
médias tout le monde le sait dès lors
tous les autres candidats qui vont se
présenter cette marie il faut que le
nombre d'écoles donc il faut qu'il y ait
des hommes du nord qui soit en pole
position bonne position donc défendre
les intérêts de nos par exemple la
classe peau ça pas normal que mal des
transports ni compétence là et que paris
des élus du nord au sud de la rue des
kicks à monter au créneau
donc oui il faut que les élus du nord
occupent des places mais vraiment des
places fondamentale des places prix
mondial pour faire des faux pour
défendre les intérêts du nobel soit 0
déçu on a bien entendu et on vous dit je
n'ai jamais dit que j'étais déçu
d'alfred marie-jeanne réalité ou
impression plus proches surtout depuis
le 3 mai mof plus et alfred marie-jeanne
ce martiniquais ma peau et celle des
finissants martiniquais m'appuie et jean
claude milot sur martiniquais mais après
tout nous sommes des martiniquais et je
suppose et je porte et je suis fermement
convaincu que tous ces hommes là aiment
leur pays
maintenant je me répète c'est pas une
question d'hommes syndicats sur le
projet
cette marie joue un rôle fondamental
dans les élections à la septième avec
tel ou tel candidat en fonction du
projet qui sera présenté dès l'instant
où les hommes du nord vont occuper des
places fondamentale des places puis
mondiale aussi de cette collectivité là
à huit secondes 10 secondes dites moi
qu'est le drapeau début d'année soit 0
jour de mon pari pourquoi pas c'est
franchement que je dis ah et puis pour
le visage
et puis problèmes guinéens au pays un
monovolume de la peau mais nous allons
arrêter
moi je pense que jamais les drapeaux
mais non
non non pas du ballet bêtise la loggia
la problème mon cap 9 m
pas de trace peau munka souffrent et
meurent est mal élu de la peau non mais
franchement nous sérieux mais la merci
vous donner son rein droit d'avoir été
ce matin avec nous rappelle que vous
êtes le maire de sète marie bonne
journée
[Musique]